hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2020 american psychological thriller
movie called do not reply
the movie begins with chelsea a young
introverted teenage girl texting with
her best friend mia
mia excitedly tells her about her close
acquaintance with a boy named dylan and
presumes that they will be dating soon
chelsea then reluctantly goes to school
with her famous cheerleader sister
christina before leaving christina
notices chelsea receives a text from an
anonymous number presumably a boy
although chelsea does not know who it is
arriving at school chelsea meets with
mia who tells her that their usual movie
night will be relocated to dylan's house
so she can have an opportunity to make
out with dylan
however dylan also invites his best
friend seth with the intention of
setting him up with chelsea while he and
mia make out during the movie night
chelsea awkwardly interacts with seth
who clearly shows interest in her and
even aggressively kisses her
chelsea is uncomfortable with the
situation and quickly leaves
the next day mia asks chelsea what
happened last night chelsea admits that
she did not feel comfortable but mia
disregards her feelings and is too busy
cuddling with dylan mia receives another
text from the same anonymous number
feeling left alone she replies to the
number and they engage in a conversation
unfortunately school security
confiscates her phone
chelsea's mother has to pick it up from
school and she punishes chelsea by not
letting her have her phone for one month
mia being a supportive friend sneaks to
her house to lend her a phone
chelsea thanks her although she admits
she is disappointed by mia always being
preoccupied with dylan
chelsea restores her chats and continues
texting with the unknown number he asks
if chelsea is a cheerleader to which she
answers yes he then asks her to send him
pictures of her in a cheerleader costume
chelsea goes to christina's room after
making sure she is not home and borrows
her cheerleader costume takes photos
with it and sends it to him sometime
later the boy asks to have a video call
with her but his camera is blurry he
admits that his phone is broken
three weeks later after intense
communication chelsea agrees to meet the
boy named brad on a date they agree to
attend a halloween party where they
could each take a bus too
chelsea hears someone shouting brad's
name in the background then brad tells
her it is his sister sadie
halloween day comes chelsea admits that
she will just stay home and pass candy
to the kids after her mother and sister
leave chelsea goes out to the party and
finally meets brad whose face is covered
with a helmet so she cannot see it
clearly brad offers her an alcoholic
drink and they drink until she is wasted
brad guides her to his car ties her
wrists and takes her to his place
chelsea wakes up in a filthy basement
brad comes sometimes to give her food
and water and begins telling her that
her name is now sadie not chelsea
if she does not obey him he tortures her
after a while chelsea decides to play
along with anything brad wants
another girl in cheerleader costume
introducing herself also as sadie comes
to free her on behalf of brad
chelsea uses the opportunity to escape
but finds herself out of the filthy
basement of a heavily locked pastel
house the other sadie whose real name is
megan warns her to not get herself into
trouble
she tells chelsea to cover her tracks by
raking the rug in the living room she
then introduces chelsea to another girl
also nicknamed sadie wearing a
cheerleader outfit and blonde hair but
her real name is heather megan helps
clean chelsea's body and outfit demands
her to dye her hair blonde too and
prepares her for dinner while chelsea is
brushing her teeth she hears a sound and
discovers in a bedroom that another girl
fell from her bed
she has a bad injury on her thigh but
when chelsea offers to help her she
dismisses her
meanwhile brad is playing with his
virtual reality gears and practices some
movements with a knife then heads down
for dinner on the way down he
hallucinates seeing a girl in front of
the mirror while teasing him
in the kitchen brad finds heather making
a cake for dinner and harasses her
heather goes to the bathroom and meets
with chelsea but she tells her bruises
is having a kitchen accident and nothing
to worry about
chelsea heather and megan then have
their outside time which is actually
just an opportunity to feel the outside
world through brad's vr device for a few
minutes
heather then tells chelsea to spare some
of her food during dinner for the
injured girl chelsea then learns the
girl was injured by brad because she was
trying to escape during dinner chelsea
cries because she misses her family then
brad talks about how chelsea's family
was looking for her however he forbids
her to talk about her family again as
brad and the girls are her family now
after the dinner chelsea learns that
heather is leaving the house because she
has been a good and obedient girl for
three years
before her release she has to do the
last performance in front of brad
chelsea goes to the injured girls room
to give her food
she learns that the girl's name is tina
a name she recognizes for missing person
news on tv
meanwhile brad asks heather to perform a
cheerleader dance in his basement while
he records it using his vr gear
however before she begins brad begins
hallucinating again
this time he remembers when he was
little and had to reluctantly welcome
his baby sister into the family sadie
received more love and attention from
his parents than him causing him to
develop hate towards her
back to his senses he secretly wields a
knife then immediately attacks and stabs
heather until she dies
he shouts that he is willing to watch
sadie die over and over again
turns out brad kidnaps cheerleader girls
and tortures them because he likes to
release his anger to his sister towards
these girls
megan communicates with chelsea through
a hole in her bedroom wall hidden behind
the nightstand
meghan is so brainwashed that she thinks
brad loves her and presumes that chelsea
is her competitor for winning brad's
heart
she also thinks that tina is jealous of
her close relationship with brad thus
trying to escape
chelsea does not understand why being
chosen by brad is a good thing then
tries to infuriate brad by misbehaving
at dinner
however brad also scolds megan for
smiling when he throws his anger at
chelsea
chelsea goes to tina's room again
tina explains that she tried to escape
because she was pregnant after being
brutally tortured by brad she lost her
baby and is now bedridden
she wants to end her suffering by
overdosing herself with brad's
painkillers which she knows are inside
brad's nightstand
she asks chelsea to help retrieve the
painkillers in exchange for anything she
knows about brad and how to possibly
escape she knows when brad is mowing his
lawn and teaches chelsea how to get out
of their locked bedroom chelsea gets the
painkillers and frantically rakes the
rug to cover her tracks but she is too
clumsy to let the pills fall onto the
floor fortunately she cleans the mess
and is back in her room just as brad
finishes mowing however brad discovers
tina's unlocked bedroom door and accuses
her of trying to escape again
he suffocates her using a pillow chelsea
observes them from the connecting
bathroom and surprisingly she asks brad
to do it
tina is glad that chelsea keeps her
promise to end her suffering however
brad is amused by chelsea's act and
thinks she can be his partner in crime
after tina is no longer breathing
chelsea is trembling because of the
adrenaline rush
brad calms her down and shows her his
videos of him torturing and murdering
heather in his vr gear
chelsea seems to enjoy the sadistic
scenes then brad plans to film another
video with megan as the victim
he assumes he can kill megan together
with chelsea during that day's dinner
brad clearly favors chelsea over meghan
making the latter jealous
brad instructs megan to help him with
testing a new vr gear after dinner in
their bedrooms chelsea warns megan that
brad wants to kill her even showing
tina's body to prove to her that brad
can truly kill someone
megan still does not believe that brad
could do that then reports chelsea to
brad
brad is furious and locks both girls in
their rooms but chelsea would not give
up
she escapes from her room frees meghan
and runs with her to brad's room where
she could show her his vr gear which
contains heather's torture video
however brad catches them locks megan in
her room and drags chelsea to the
basement he intends to torture chelsea
but she puts up a fight megan
frantically escapes from her room and
gets herself a knife before heading down
to the basement to help chelsea they
both beat brad and stab him in the back
then frantically grab his keys and run
upstairs
brad manages to muster enough strength
to get out of the basement and goes
after the girls who are opening the
front door but chelsea finally defeats
him by smashing his head with his vr
helmet finally out of the house chelsea
and megan approach passersby and ask for
help chelsea contacts her family to
inform them that she is now safe however
she is reluctant to talk about her
traumatic experience with a therapist
that her parents assigned
meanwhile brad hallucinates in prison
seeing sadie coming after him with a
knife
sometime later two thirteen-year-old
girls are scrolling through social media
talking about 17 year old boys they
would like to date online then they
forfeit their age to 16 and one of them
gets a chat from a boy the chat format
is like what chelsea received from brad
indicating many online predators are
still lurking on the internet subscribe
to watch more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching